- To me that defines me
as a great entrepreneur.
Somebody who's trying
to put other people on
in all his activity.
(upbeat music)
(cheering)
You got your perspective.
(plane engine roaring)
(crowd cheering)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
(upbeat music)
- Gary, how is it going?
- Well, my friend, how are you?
I am honestly incredible.
- That makes me happy.
- I am beyond amazing.
I'm on this 21 day Deepak
Chopra, abundance meditation.
And it's, life-changing.
- Good for you.
- Should we dive in?
- [Gary] I would love that.
- Yes, done and done.
I wanna welcome back
Gary V, AKA Vaynerchuk,
back in my field podcast.
An incredible entrepreneur,
New York Times best seller,
author, speaker, internet
personality, businessman,
honest hustler, music fan,
investor, you name it.
He is that.
So how we usually start
is thoughts, feelings,
emotions, beliefs on the inside,
create your outside exterior, Gary.
So how are you feeling
right now in this moment?
- Grateful.
I'm feeling very grateful.
I'm feeling optimistic.
I'm feeling motivated.
Patient, I'm feeling patient.
I'm feeling curious,
curious comes to mind.
Happy, good.
- Good.
Is there ever times when you're not those?
And if so, how do you best deal with them?
- Yeah, things pop in.
Now that I'm 45 and know a
lot of people intimately,
I've come to realize a lot
less often than most people.
I do think gratitude and
optimism, accountability.
Tenacity, I call it GOAT thinking.
Gratitude, optimism,
accountability, and tenacity
lead to a very good framework.
- Yes, the (indistinct) version .
- Yes.
So when I get upset or feel down,
here are the things that happen.
I'm like a very good fighter.
One punch to the face, never.
One top thing in business,
my day to day, never.
Loss of a big client, great person quits,
and HR headache that
I'm upset about people
not being nice to each other,
a million things that happen
when you're an entrepreneur
with 2000 employees, never.
Six beautiful shots in a row.
If you think about what Buster
Douglas did to Mike Tyson
in that round, those were
six clean shots in a row
I go down.
And so
when that happens or
what sort of blue moon
where I wake up and I'm
not in the best mood,
normally historically on
just probably fatigue,
even though on the record
'cause I think I get labeled
unfairly around hustle porn.
I've been for ever talking
about seven, eight,
nine hours of sleep.
I fight for sleep more than anything,
but I fight secondarily to
be productive while awake,
if you have big ambition.
So that's the nuance.
Nonetheless, sometimes I wake up,
I always go to the same place.
Gratitude and perspective.
- Yeah.
- I immediately go, I'm sorry,
let me just get this
context for you to build on.
I go into, yes, I might
not be in the mood to work
or yes, somebody might be sick
or my child might be stressed
or a dad might be upset, but damn it,
everyone's actually alive
and healthy and like...
and so I very much go to
that end of all places
of health and happiness.
Health as happiness, excuse me.
And so that usually shakes me out of it.
Like I basically go into yeah,
but if this wasn't going
on and I got a phone call
at three o'clock in the
morning while I was sleeping
last night that said X, Y,
Z atrocious thing happened,
would I be happier?
Of course not.
And so that keeps most things
in very deep perspective.
- Absolutely.
It's funny you talk about
sleep because that was
actually my next question.
I mean, I used to struggle
with sleep to a point
that it would be very on
and off and then it would
affect my day.
And this is, I'd like
to speak from a place
of the difference between
activity and action.
So action is like, I'm hungry,
I'm gonna go get some food,
that's a spontaneous action.
Activity is I'm not really
hungry, but I'm nibbling at food.
Like the activity of say washing dishes-
- 100%
- Is the chore or the
action of washing dishes
is actually feeling the
warm water, the bubbles,
hearing the water, go down the sink hall.
The difference is you
become it rather than just
separate from it.
- I like it.
- And I think as I've
started operating like that,
my energy levels have
gone through the roof.
So even like speaking with, on a podcast,
is speaking absolute
truth with full action,
not activity, not just mumbling
or speaking some things.
And since I've I doing that,
I mean I'm in bed literally
'cause I have a 14 month old.
I go to bed at 8:00 p.m., I
do my 15 minute meditation,
I read constantly, there's no
TV, there's no distraction,
no phones.
And I sleep.
- I would argue reading is
far more of a distraction
than people...
people put reading on a
pedestal and TV and phone
on a negative.
I don't think it's stimulation
because I'm sure you agree
with me as a reader, you
can get plenty stimulated
while reading.
- 100%.
- I actually think it's peace of mind.
- Yes.
Well there's actually no
such thing as peace of mind.
Peace of no mind.
'Cause when you have
mind, there's no peace.
- So for me, whether it's
that context or juxtaposition,
whether it's ambition balanced
with complacency of happiness
and acceptance,
I always sleep well
and the only times I
don't is when I'm anxious,
it's not super complicated.
And I've had a couple of
major things in my life
through the years that
have made me anxious
and I don't sleep as well.
It's not super complicated.
And so that makes a lot of sense to me.
And I think when you were just talking
and this has always
been a big thing for me,
I love my process.
When you were talking,
being right the water,
like that's the only thing I've ever done.
It's why I've been so specific,
is the word I would use,
such a bad student when I'm not a dope,
but I could have easily done it.
But I had so much conviction
in the passion of my process
that I was willing to punt school
to work on my skill of observing people
and doing entrepreneurship,
whether that was baseball cards
or reading sports card magazines
or reading wine magazines
when I got into wine.
I've always been so into the process of
I enjoyed and continue to
enjoy when I'm underestimated
and not paid attention to far
more than the alternative.
I get great pleasure out of
the early days of wine library
when nobody knew who I was,
building, I'm a builder,
building that business.
I don't need the accolades.
I don't need the attention.
I don't need the trophies.
I don't need the money.
I need my process.
And I think that's what
you're referring to.
And when you're about the process
versus what the process gives you,
I think the relationship
changes dramatically.
- I think that's a difference.
I mean me cause following you,
it's not about the things that you do
is how you do them for me.
'Cause I'm a studier of put people too.
So you're reading a documentary and I know
everything around you,
I already know that's your thought process
because it's the law of attraction,
you are the magnet to that.
And then seeing you the
way you do things is you
very much lead with the heart.
And I understand yet
we think with the head
and all that type of stuff,
the head is in the past,
the heart is in the now and the future.
And I study you and I see that
in every single thing you do
because you lead with the heart.
- Thank you.
Because it goes back to gratitude.
You can't imagine what
that feels like for me,
just hearing that.
I think humility...
I think I'm extremely
misunderstood by a lot of people
and I actually weirdly enjoy it.
Not because I'm like evil to myself,
because it educates me.
It's a thesis in what I believe,
which is communication and
context are everything.
And so I think my energy,
my natural communication energy,
easily disguises a lot
of things I'm up to.
So when I hear you say that,
I'm flattered by, cause I think
you have to do a little bit,
you have to spend a few seconds on it
'cause I'm not a very easy read.
(Lou laughs)
Right?
- Yes.
- And I don't know if
that was your experience,
what you first felt as
actually this could be fun
for the audience.
Do you recall the first
time you came across me,
do you have a recollection
of what your hot take was?
Because I do think I invoke
very opposite reactions
the first time someone consumes me.
- You know what it is?
Is you put the power back to
the person asking the question.
And I think that's what drew me to you
because we all...
this is why I do this podcast because
your thoughts, your
emotions, your beliefs,
your expectations, your negativity,
your positivity that defines
your whole existence.
And I, and on a spiritual practical level,
I'm a spiritual practical guy,
my mum was a single parent of five kids,
I knew about the hustle,
I knew about all that type of stuff.
The only difference is
the hustling on the street
and hustling and business
it's the same thing,
it's just you're
communicating differently.
The emotion and the
feeling is still the same,
but now I've dropped the
notion of how the fuck
am I gonna get there?
And I know it's gonna come.
- And what's even more fun,
and this is how it's always been for me
is it's gonna come as redefined.
When people were listening to just now
and I'm getting goosebumps
through this interview,
which is fun and that means,
I know we're hitting on something.
Success or what's gonna come,
legacy or having it is
always the by-product.
But if you can really get to the place of
to your point believing that truth,
well, then you get to become the person
who defines that truth.
I often say like my
ambitions are to be one
of the great entrepreneurs of all time.
And I get met by a lot of my friends
and definitely by the comments
section of social media,
with incredible amounts of
resistance of no around,
well, Jeff Bezos and Elon Musk and Oprah
they're gonna make more money.
And I'm like, you've defined
the greatest entrepreneur
based on money.
I've defined for me,
the greatest entrepreneur
is the one who a,
'cause I agree at some
level you're gonna say that,
you can't say you're the
greatest singer of all time
and not have a Grammy or a hit,
like there is market dynamics
that you have to respect.
And I respect that.
I think I will be
financially successful enough
to get into the debate
when my career is over.
Karma, I don't see anyone
as passionate of giving
free game at scale on a daily
basis and really meaning it
in the macro and the micro.
And I believe that I don't
know what else to tell you.
Like, I'm very busy in that.
My time is extremely valuable.
When I do this podcast again,
I do it because I like you
and I'm cheering for you.
- And I appreciate it.
- I'm being very frank.
I'm not unaware that
there's gonna be new people
listening that didn't
listen the first time,
or maybe I say something a different way
and they've come into this, not liking me,
but they love you.
And they're like, wait a minute.
I know that,
but I also know that a
fresh interview with me
gives you leverage to get the next guy.
Like I'm aware of that.
And so to me that defines
me as a great entrepreneur.
Somebody who's trying
to put other people on
in all his activities,
whether that's financially,
whether that's giving something.
I'd rather give me $10,000
in cash for this podcast
than be on it for these 45 minutes,
because I can do more with that money.
Like, so sometimes it's
money, sometimes it's time,
sometimes it's a public co-sign,
I'll give you another thing.
Sometimes it's already
happened with you for example,
sometimes it's saying
something behind the scenes
when someone's debating to do this or not.
And I'm just using you,
we've interacted so little,
this happens to me times 100,000 a month.
And I think good intent,
karma, caring about others,
self esteem and self competence
that you can get yours
without tearing anyone else
down gets you into a place
where you wanna build everyone else up.
- I see beauty in that.
You see, because,
was Buddha an entrepreneur?
Yes
- I think so.
- Was Jesus, yes.
Any spiritual leader
who, again, as I said-
- [Gary] I totally believe that.
- Who lead from the heart
and then like you said,
the accolades thing and
all that type of stuff.
That's acceptance, we don't need that.
It's like, for example, this podcast,
I do an episode with
guests who who inspire me.
And then I do an episode
with guests who send me
like really heartfelt courageous messages
about their personal lives, about,
I had someone on last week
who wanted to move to LA,
told his mom he was moving
to LA seven months ago,
his brother's Oding in the
bathroom, like courageous.
I couldn't say that at his age to anyone,
if even a bunch of those
things happened to me.
And I was like, well, would
you like to talk about it?
And he was like, "Oh my
God, I would love to."
And we spoke it, we broke down
and his mum made him feel
guilty about him moving,
even though he's trying to
support her and everything else.
And I just had to say,
look until you can actually physically
help yourself mentally, you
can't really help anyone else.
It's the same thing for me.
Like I have niggling negative...
Like I did the 21 day on
day six of this meditation
of abundance,
there's some people who
don't live in abundance.
They live completely
shut off and their life
is exactly that.
And I try and tell them
step out of yourself
and study your life.
You're exactly where
you're supposed to be based
on who you are.
Accountability.
- Accountability.
Accountability is the key
to the unlock of happiness
that nobody wants to use.
Because they don't like
the short-term pain
of accountability without
realizing the longterm happiness
that it brings.
- Yes.
And I think that's what
made me listen to you.
It was giving that back to the
person and then questioning,
being like, "Oh shit, yes."
And then seeing their reaction and seeing
this whole sheet on their body.
- That's right.
What ends up happening with
me because of what I do,
it's like a mirror with pressure.
And the reason a lot of people
don't respond well to me
is it's manifesting someone in them
that they're not happy to expose.
They don't want me poking at their zit.
- Yes.
And it's funny cause I know like,
I can imagine that your
mind is always busy.
It's always onto cause that's who you are.
I read a book talk which was about speed.
And we're all busy,
I was reading my daughter a
bedtime story and she was like,
"Again."
And I was like, maybe I
really have to like...
I've got things to do, I love you,
but you need to go to sleep.
And then I started reading this book,
books come to me like that.
It's not really me searching is kind of
they come to me when I need them.
And I needed that because
the guy wrote the book
because it was the exact same situation.
And he was like, what am I
actually doing that's in a rush?
- It's prioritization
and selfless, selfish.
I think about that a lot.
And you have to be okay.
I also think you have to be careful
not to over judge yourself.
It is okay to be looking at your phone
around something you're doing in your life
at the expense of your young child,
who just wants your attention.
Now it's not okay to do that
for a sustained period of time
where you now have neglect on your child.
But I watch parents go
the reverse, my friend,
when they like beat themselves
up for a 42nd lapse,
and I'm like, what are you doing?
Why are you...
And I think it's back
to finding that balance
because I think you're right.
You wanna get something on the podcast,
prep for a podcast and
you're like, wait a minute,
16 more minutes with darling,
this is something I'll always remember
plus I'm putting deposits
in a relationship.
I'm gonna care much more about
than if I did a solid
interview with Gary V.
I think that's absolutely right.
I also try, when we talk
about things like this
to bring up the counter, like
I just did, which is like,
and sometimes it's okay to be
selfish for your own ambitions
and your own process.
Find your balance, make
sure you're not consistently
doing one end or the other.
- Yes, absolutely.
That's why now I have the
nanny and four times a week.
And during the other
three days are completely
dedicated to her.
So our evenings because I
understand the power that I have.
So, and also now I know
that raising my daughter
brings me abundance.
In a sense where I'm my
own social experiment,
so, I wouldn't say I've
removed myself from society,
but I've removed the
distractions, the activity,
from my life.
So that everything now is key,
and I know exactly where it's going.
- I think it's a super interesting thing.
I've said a lot and I don't
know if you've heard this,
but it seems like you might have,
I talk a lot about living in a cocoon.
If you go to search.garyvaynerchuk.com,
I have a search engine.
If you search cocoon,
you'll be stunned how often I say that,
and that's what you just said.
I believe so much of my happiness
has been living in a cocoon,
which is wild because I
also think I'm an incredibly
successful voice of the current.
- Yeah, you're a people person.
- I'm a people person.
So I know what's going on.
I'm not affected by what's going on.
I know what's going on on Clubhouse,
I know what's going on in VR,
I know who's popping in
hip hop and in sports
and an influencers.
I know what's going on in geopolitics.
I'm like really awake to so much,
but completely detached from.
- Yes.
And that's beautiful.
I fucking love that.
You see it's the same thing.
When you focus on poverty,
it brings more poverty.
What we need to focus on
is the solution to poverty,
whether that's educational schools or,
or jobs or career or anything,
there's so many different
things like COVID,
I'm not consumed by it.
I know that it's going on in the world
and everyone has consumed
by is affected by it.
What's my solution to it?
I can help people financially.
I can educate them on
getting their mind right,
I can send them mindful meditations,
I can have them put their mind
into thinking about health
or better health instead of...
course for me, I know again
I'm practically spiritually,
but illnesses are physical
manifestations in the body,
which to tell you to stop
doing what you're doing
emotionally, physically, environmentally.
- 100%, I believe in that.
So I believe in math and an art,
I believe in black and white and gray,
I think the reason people
struggle with a lot of
what we're talking about here
when we go into this realm,
is because they choose sides.
Steve jobs, and I don't
know all the details,
do I believe that you can just sit there
and will it mentally?
Sometimes.
I really genuinely like, I
don't know what, I'm sorry,
I'm on the record,
sometimes I believe the brain can.
Do I believe that's always answer?
No, I do not.
I think sometimes math is a good answer.
You got to figure out
when and how and what,
but once we become a
culture of and versus or,
this is a very big point
of mine in general,
something I'm gonna be talking about more
because I just unveiled
it a little bit here
with a little more simply say it a lot,
but I'm starting really get,
I'm like, wait a minute.
The reason so much works
for me is I live in and,
and all these people want it to be or,
they're so obsessed with
it to be one or the other
when it is always and.
Even if you think about
our religious divides,
our racial divides, our
social divides, our country,
America has racist, Europe
has the antisemitic issue,
like it's because of or.
Why can't it be and?
- I think my perspective of how I live is
I don't know shit about anything.
And there's beauty in that.
The old me used to fear the unknown,
now I fucking love it.
I'm welcoming it with open arms,
bring it because I don't know anything.
This is great.
And I think it puts you on
a level plateau of being-
- One of the things that I do worry about,
like being transparent is
I get mad when people think
I'm egotistical because
I'm so conviction oriented.
Because really, if you asked
me what speak about traits
that got you here,
I would argue humility is at the top.
Humility and patience.
Yet, I seem frantic and
borderline egotistical
on almost every video clip
because I'm passionate conviction
and I'm fast.
So my human manifestation
of communication style
is one thing my actions as a human
are completely the opposite.
- See, I don't see that.
Because, but then again
I read (indistinct)
on outside
you don't lead with ego.
Otherwise you would attract
egotistical situations to you
and that's just not who you are.
- You're uncomfortably thoughtful
on this issue my friend.
I think you could have done it without
you being humble or like me flattering.
Like, I think you're pretty
aware that you come at it
a little bit different than the masses.
- Yeah.
- Luckily I think I'm
also interesting enough
that makes people look
a second or third time.
And most people are intuitive
enough that if they get
enough context, they're
like, wait a minute,
nothing's, I mean.
And I also probably in a weird way,
manifest a little bit
of the underestimation.
I do think I'm extremely attracted
to the underdog situation
because of all my circumstances.
And I sometimes wonder if I, a little bit,
like for example,
you may know this since you consume you,
you've got a lot of contexts.
My team is so frustrated
that I don't talk about
being smart.
(Lou laughs)
The number one conversation
with my inner circle
in my content is you don't
tell people you're smart.
And I rebuttal with how is
that gonna bring anyone value?
- Yeah.
- And they have gotten
smarter than the rebuttal,
which is like, Hey, that
validation might help you affect
more people.
And then you'd start having the game of
who do you get, who you don't get.
And you go through that whole thing,
but I get it.
And I think you're right.
But I also know that most
people can't see that.
- Yeah.
And I don't think you need to say, I mean,
I never went to school I know you didn't,
so I never believed I was smart
because I didn't have the
accreditation up until
a certain point.
And I was like, actually-
- same.
what a smart-
(indistinct)
Wait a minute.
Why was I successful both
financial and happiness
a lot more than almost
the rest of my high school
combined class?
You start getting more
thoughtful and wisdom oriented.
You start realizing the
framework of life is different
and you start building on that.
- Yeah.
So in terms of like, during
this whole time period,
I mean, to be honest, like
during this transition
from March til now, it's been,
I don't know what's going on in the world.
I don't consume myself with it.
I just know I can help
the people around me.
And then we rise together.
How have you adapted as a person mentally,
business-wise or should I say transitioned
during this period?
I mean, cause you're pretty online anyway,
so I feel like yo could have
just taken a step forward
or whatever.
How have you transitioned as a person,
as a human during this time?
(sighing)
- I've taken an advantage.
- It's a great one.
- Yeah.
I've taken advantage.
I've been the kind of
person that always loves
Christmas break because
everyone else is off too.
- Me too.
That's the only time
when no one's trying to-
- So knowing that everyone
else was in COVID too
was very good for me.
And I said, you know, I'm
going to spend more time
with my family, see my
parents so much more,
I'm going to rekindle friendships.
So like great friends that
you just get out of patterns
of communication with.
So it really focused on Kevin
Rose, founder of dig.com.,
for example, Ashton.
Like some friends, my college friends,
the 301 the spot group, big
shout out to Mount Ida College.
So I rekindled .
I got deeper into my
kids, so that's been huge.
I've gotten very,
I've gained (mumbling)
and I've learned how
muscle mass is gained.
I've probably gained seven
to 10 pounds of muscle.
I've gotten more sleep.
I have business developed at
a level I've never had before
using LinkedIn because now I have a laptop
and I'm doing multiple things at once
because they didn't have
a laptop for five years
at all my phone.
So double screens has
made me more efficient.
But most of all,
let me tell you a very thoughtful thing
that I think you'll enjoy
because I know you now.
I've taken advantage by
even becoming more competent
and conviction oriented around my beliefs.
I believed because I
went through it with 911
and the economic crisis,
but it had been a long time,
and the companies and
things I was doing were
so much smaller than what I'm doing now.
It was in my belief that
I was a wartime general,
that when shit gets bad, I get better.
This was a real challenge.
Vayner X, my holding
company in VaynerMedia.
And I have a lot of
companies underneath it,
fell in the middle.
So we got no government support.
We weren't small enough,
we weren't big enough.
We were in growth mode.
So we didn't have a lot of
profit the last three years.
So we weren't sitting on cash.
We had multiple major clients say
they're not going to pay us on time
immediately the day COVID hit.
I had to let go of 80 people,
which is all 80 of them
sit in my stomach and my heart right now,
let alone a year ago.
We had to innovate product and services.
We did all of those wildly well.
Including expanding, starting companies,
including investments that
I made doing extremely well,
including me being wildly right about
proper football and
basketball and sports cards
as an investment alternative alt.
So I sit here a year later, happier,
more fulfilled and more successful,
the end.
- Beautiful.
Growth that's evolution.
- I think that there
are people who do well
in trying circumstances.
I just believe it.
I believe that's why there
is a term called wartime
and peacetime generals.
I think that's why some people have a plan
until they get punched in the face
like Mike Tyson said.
I think I'm extremely good at
getting punched in the face
because I think I was punched
in the face for the first six,
seven years of my life.
Moving a lot, language
barriers, fear of immigration,
not speaking the language,
getting picked on a lot,
losing, losing, losing,
losing, it became a comfort.
- Yeah.
It's not always..
For me it's
all my experience that all
the good, the bad, the ugly,
all that type of everything
that happened to me,
I've welcomed it.
I've loved it because I wouldn't
be where I'm at right now.
And you know what, I genuinely
like where I'm at right now.
I'm starting to love it.
Like I'm genuinely
starting to open up myself
and being like, Oh shit,
this is fucking good.
And you know, you don't
realize your childhood
when you're in it until
you actually have kids.
And then you're like, and
I see my daughter's life,
I'm like, yo, there was
some bad shit that happened,
but that's okay because I'm good.
And I don't dwell on that.
And it's this points back
to my next thing of dreams.
I'd love to know because
there's the one defining moment during...
I was working at Sony ATV,
I lost my job, it was a great job.
And I had, I wouldn't say self-doubts,
I knew I didn't get along with the CEO,
I knew that things wouldn't happen.
And I knew spiritually
that something was coming
and I couldn't change
that thought process.
And then one night when I got let go
of all that type of stuff, but me I adapt.
So I have more than one revenue of income.
So I know when one goes down,
the other will pick up
the pace if I focus on it.
And I had this one dream
and I don't like open doors
in my house.
It must be a respect thing
that the doors should be closed.
And utility room in my dream
was open and it was dark.
So I opened the door and
something grabbed my arm
and I couldn't pull it back.
And in the dream, I couldn't scream,
I couldn't do anything, and
I woke up and I was like,
Oh, you need to let go.
You need to let go of
that whole situation.
You did it, you spent six
years, it was amazing,
you signed some of the
most biggest artists,
you had some of the biggest
hits and you need to let go.
And the minute I did that,
just things that I wasn't even focused on,
even though I was focused
on abundance, came in.
And now I'm in a process
of like buying catalogs
of those songwriters for
amazing for equity companies
and catalogs I never even
would even think or dream about
are coming in.
And I feel like it's
minimal effort for me now
because I'm being...
I'm floating on the river
and I'm going with the flow.
Kind of where I'm at.
And I'd love to know about
if there's a defining dream
or any dreams that you
have or any cause for me,
they're symbols that they
break down your whole day,
your whole life up to that point.
And I'd love to dive a
little bit on that with you.
- That's a great, great question.
Dreams, right?
- Dreams.
See, I got Gary thinking.
I need more of that.
- It's great, I appreciate it.
I love thinking and
thoughtfulness and pondering.
The dreams that get ahold of
me are a little different.
First of all,
I think I am as grateful as one can be
when it comes around profession.
When I tell you my profession
brings me zero anxiety ever,
ever, that is actually the truth.
I just don't think money
and work and business
means anything even though I
am probably one of the most
recognized internet
entrepreneurs on the planet.
- But that's why it makes you that.
- No shit.
Karma to answer your question.
I dream a lot.
As a kid, I dreamt a lot
about a family reunion
in Russia and every time
the plane would crash
in Siberia and every time
it would be a different mix
of my 12 relatives who survived with me
and then we would try to survive
and then I would always wake up.
This was a very aggressive,
recurring dream.
I dream a lot about
the health and wellbeing of my,
I think I fear only one thing,
the health and wellbeing
of the people I love.
And so when I think about dreams,
I don't remember most
dreams like most people,
but the ones that as you were talking
and I was pondering and I kind
of paused and said dreams,
I realized, huh?
Pretty much the shit I remember
is around extremely negative situations
that when I wake up, I'm so
fucking grateful it's not true
that no matter what the day
has in store me in front,
as long as it's not that, I
think I got very fucking lucky.
I think I grew up in a culture where
my parents and grandparents generation
died so young in Soviet Russia,
people were dying in their 40s and 50s.
Alcoholism, depression,
it's the Soviet union.
I mean, one of the worst
regimes in the history of time
for humans, suppression at scale.
That I think I'm so affected by it
that it's in my blood, in my subconscious.
It's very hard for me
to worry about anything,
but like they say in Russia
(speaks in foreign language)
to good health, that's all I ever heard.
It's all I ever knew.
To good health, to good
health, to good health.
I never heard anybody choose to prosperity
in my entire life.
I, to this day and my friends
know this, when we do cheers,
sometimes it'll be like a big deal.
I've had some big exits in my career.
That's a big moments.
And like some of my
American friends are just
not even American, like friends,
like to Rezi our big company
exit or to Gary being
on Conan O'Brien or to whatever.
Never I'm always like,
no, no, no to good health,
boom, boom.
I think it's my religion.
And I think it plays
out in a lot of places.
And I think when it comes to dreams,
I just realized it plays out there too.
- Wow.
And that kind of brings
me to my next point is,
I don't know if you've ever
dove into the multi-verse
or any of that type of things of say,
what would Gary be doing now,
if he wasn't doing what he's doing now?
And if you've put enough
energy, like, for example,
you said the dream of, of
the plane and (indistinct)
probably I know I'm going
a bit farfetched, but,
and I believe this there's
probably another you
who is living that existence,
tapping into that existence.
So for example, you,
and this is why it's so
important to me, for example,
I wanted to play soccer.
Like I played semi-pro in the UK,
and then I got injured and
I kept getting injured,
I kept getting injured
and I can trace it back
to my negativity of when I
used to start a game is like,
don't get injured.
Instead of just being in the
game and enjoying the game.
And I would always get injured.
What would Gary V be doing now,
if he wasn't doing what he's doing?
- I have two very good answers on this,
because this question
comes very natural to me.
One, I would be a guidance
counselor in a school.
I get incredible pleasure,
hence, back to something
we touched on earlier
of providing guidance through
words to young people.
I love it.
Being a guidance
counselor in a high school
would fulfill me tremendously.
- Yep.
- Number two,
I would be,
by the way, I'd be the guidance
counselor and definitely
a head coach of one of the
teams that I would be savage
on the pitch or on the basketball court.
Number two,
I would be a scientist who
went to some remote place,
like the mountains in Peru,
studying a very specific narrow species
for 26 years in a wild
only to come back out
and write a book or make a documentary
of the pink tailed goats.
The only other thing I can
think of that I enjoy more
than pontificating debate
to change perspective,
to lead to more good in the world
is the work required to watch,
to be able to give the advice.
I believe I've been in...
what's that.
- That's at the heart.
That's you Gary.
- I think I've been
observing my whole life.
I think people hear me cut
off people on a podcast
or talk a lot, and they don't
realize that 93% of my life
is listening.
You don't see me every minute.
You just see,
I'm very good at creating
content and distributing it
on the internet, so you
think I'm always talking,
but what I'm actually doing
is listening all the time
so that my talking has value.
- And I think that's your background,
that's your upbringing,
that's the struggles,
that's all that type of
stuff, because I'm the same.
I'm always, I'm watching, I'm listening,
I'm learning constantly,
I'm never not learning.
I used to think, "Oh."
when I was younger,
we'd have these like mentors, om.
And actually it was actually
pretty good to be honest.
And it was like Barings Bank,
which was one of the
biggest banks in the UK.
And it was like underprivileged kids.
So you got a bunch of us
poor kids running around
at this bank and he would
sit there and he explained
to you the fundamentals of
banking and money and saving
and all that type of stuff.
And I was like, "Holy shit"
I said, "I wanna learn how to...
throw me in a room of these people,
and I wanna learn how to make money."
So I would study how they spoke
and how they resonated, what they wore.
I go into meetings and I'd dress decently
and then someone..
he was one, she told me
that the two things you need
in life, when you take a meeting
is a nice watch in a bag.
So I would get a nice watch at a time,
which was like a 500 bucks watch.
But to me that was a lot of money.
And it was like, I got this
beautiful black briefcase.
And every time I would
go in, they were like,
"Oh, nice watch him bag."
And I was like, "Yeah, I'm
gonna make some money."
- You know it's funny back
to sandbagging myself.
I was thinking, when
you were just talking,
this is something I've got to figure out.
'Cause it's fascinating.
I actually, I'm gonna
self-diagnose and I have some
insight to this.
I actually think that I
like the process so much
that I actually don't want the riches
that are associated
with my natural talent.
That the reason I never wore a suit
or got a watch or a handbag,
the reason I cursed on
stage every day of my life
when I started my career,
when everyone told me I could
be one of the great speakers
of all time, but I had
to dropped the cursing,
(Lou laughs)
was I wasn't willing to
compromise what naturally felt
happy and intuitively felt right to me
for what others perceived
would be short-term success.
Or I've literally sabotaged
myself to slow down
the acceleration of my
destiny because I enjoy
the taste of the process so much.
- Yeah.
But you know it's this warped
view on what's right or wrong.
There isn't one.
- There isn't one.
- I actually just read a
book on that yesterday.
I'm reading a ton of this,
this author called Osho.
Who's amazing but he was like
one of the most controversial
people since Jesus
and he like breaks everything
down from everything
pretty much in terms of accolades.
It's like he had this one
guy who was an Indian author
who wrote beautiful poetry and
got no recognition in India.
It was terrible.
All that type of stuff and
then transformed into English
and then won the Nobel Prize
or was offered the Nobel Prize,
and he was like, "I
didn't fucking want it.
I didn't write it for this.
I wrote it because I love
doing what I'm doing."
And same as you, you love
doing what you're doing.
So naturally the success,
the financials that everything else comes
with the love in doing what you're doing.
- That gentlemen is a little bit more,
whether it's pure or to one side,
especially while my parents
are alive, I'll take them all.
I'll take every prize.
I don't take the prizes that are fake.
I get offered all the
time to be man of this
and winner of that.
And I know that they're
just schemes to get me
to buy a table and they're not true
and they're not based on merit.
But yeah, I get it.
I just, listen, I don't mind a trophy,
if I've earned it, I love it.
That's why I don't like the middle.
I don't like the judges.
I'm not there for the
Olympics where the German
or Russian judge can fuck me up.
'Cause that's subjectivity
and that's politics.
I'm here for merit.
I can deal with the booing and the hissing
in social media because I know
how the movie is gonna end.
- Yeah.
Beautiful.
I'll tell you what, you are the shit.
(Gary laughing)
I just want two points for
me because it's something
that I've kind of stumbled
at or not somewhat across,
I was always raised,
my mom was always like,
don't buy anything unless
you got physical cash for it.
So I was always, credit
for me wasn't a thing
or credit history or any
of that type of shit.
And I had to build that up for now.
Now I'm starting to realize that my money
can be making money for me
instead of remaining stagnant.
So obviously I've started
investing in Bitcoin
all that kind of stuff.
- It's so funny how much
similarities you and I have.
I'm very similar.
How old are you?
- I am 35.
- It's amazing.
Do you know that I was...
I was 34 years old when I
came to that realization?
- Yeah.
I was pretty much homeless..
from 25, 26.
- Yeah.
Stop right there.
Actually I'm sorry to interrupt,
but I want to make a huge
point for the audience
because it's gonna be a nice bow
it's cause it was our perspective.
That's all.
Forget about anything else.
(indistinct)
Forget about all that because
there's plenty of people poor
who believe in the stock market.
There's plenty people who are rich,
who believe in sit.
Like it was just our perspective.
Then we learned, and then we readjust it.
And guess what?
I do both.
I still sit, trust me.
I'm still an immigrant at heart.
I still have a little
cash pile that I'll never
touch no matter what, because
if the whole world burns,
I need to make that.
And to your point, I've
crypto and I have cash,
and I have assets.
I even have some tulips in a safe,
just in case those things come back.
So like, I'm with you on that.
- 100%.
It's funny because
the harder I work mentally,
the less I make it financially.
And I'm not talking,
you work hard,
but your mental state is
at a point where you know.
When I was walking hard,
I didn't know shit.
I didn't know the working
hard was the struggle.
You see what I'm saying?
So nothing would come in.
Now I'm open, and I work smart.
To me, it doesn't feel like
work anymore, it's love.
And my question for you, it would be-
- Self awareness, oh boy, does that.
God, if we could get
self-awareness and self-love
on a pedestal and culture,
we'd be in a much better place.
- I mean, for me, that's what it is.
I don't see-
- For me, it is too.
- I don't see negativity,
I don't see positivity,
if it comes in, I can flick it away.
- It just is.
- But that, because
it's a lack of humility
and it's also a rise of entitlement.
There'll be no confusion my friend.
Entitlement is poison.
- Yeah.
The whole thing,
this whole argument of
privilege versus no privilege,
but a privileged person
doesn't know their privilege.
That's why it's privilege.
A person who isn't privileged
wants to be privileged,
but doesn't understand that.
It's like...
because I read all these
comments and I have a ton of
not celebrity friends,
but people who I sign,
who are talented people
like musicians and stuff.
And you see their comments,
you've always had, for
example, Billie Eilish,
her parents, actors, and actresses,
she's never struggled, but
she has her own struggles.
- Oh my gosh.
- She couldn't-
- For this (indistinct) on the record.
I think it's much more challenging
being my son to being me.
- Yeah, 100%.
Same for my daughter.
- I would never want that path.
Because no matter what he accomplishes,
'cause I can already see he's
got entrepreneurial stuff,
nobody...
so he has to get insular.
If he's on, be able to get
insular and he'll always
have that as a very big thing
that hangs over his head.
- Yes.
- The end.
- Oh, I don't. ..
I think it is so
uncomfortably inappropriate
to make assumptions of
someone else's struggles.
- Yes.
- You could see a very
rich white male in America
and they're like, he's privileged.
And I'm like, or he's deeply
insecure from bad parenting
and he's mentally completely unprivileged.
I think the greatest privilege
in the world is peace of mind
or on mind how you put it.
- No mind.
So to me, one day there'll
be able to show that.
One day you can pick me up
for my grave, test me for it,
see that I was off the
charts and then you could say
I was privileged because you'll be right.
'Cause this operating system and my dome
has given me everything.
- Yeah.
I see you're pointing to the wrong spot.
You're supposed to point
it at middle of the chest.
- Heart.
I just, I'm just very
grateful to be on the show,
to have the people I care about
to be alive for all of it.
I've got to run, but I
appreciate you, thank you.
- Thank you man.
Gary, seriously.
(air whooshing)
(indistinct)
- What's up, it's Gary V.
First of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also wanna ask you,
please subscribe because my commitment
and exploration of YouTube
is about to explode stories,
polls, more content, more engagement,
more surprise, and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it.
And I hope I see you soon.